you know the other thing Mike when you
think about it Dirk knows how to play he
knows what his role is at times it does
work under a man he knew what was it
that he knew always have to have you on
the floor at the end of the Bulls game
the bat in the open court doing it as a
facilitator Jordan making his presence
felt on the inside Smith able to fend
off Taj Gibson and collect the ball for
Dallas
[Applause]
slam dunks well you're looking here and
then there's a dunk from Georgia peas
and last season than any other year it
is last year's 100 die in the beam
throws it inside George hello that's
Paul rewarding there daddy plays well
then in the shadow of his brother Wow
Jordan putback dunk Smith with an
explosive move to the realm of his ACL
surgery Matthews went off the
three-point line not great shor no
express yourself DJ and one god of
drawing Alex Len over to the missed shot
[Applause]
bats have it back locked at DeAndre to
finish right as the shot clock was about
to run out nearly on this season
[Music]
now all of us lost it looka got it back
and finds Jordan points Friday against
New York last night he had 11 points and
three blocked shots running the floor is
shortened and he catches from Lucca and
finishes with authority up tough it's
only going to continue longest
redirected to didn't Smith jr. and he'll
throw up to the alley-oop for DeAndre
Jordan on the move went on top Smith
caught inside turning slamming DeAndre
Jordan who's almost a glide path there's
the lava in a perfect spot and I've been
doing the smart thing coming down with
you get himself on balance
[Music]
[Applause]
Barnes with the drive back dump DeAndre
Jordan that's a very good job by EF
state that's beautiful oh man yes what
they great leap for DeAndre this is
going to be an Eric Bates turnover
finney-smith comes away with a ball for
the bounce
Harris got around tirade the open court
they're really good there's a lot from
Harris just like guys they've bonded the
community big bang so is throwing the
alley-oop to DeAndre lost intense
special comebacks in the last couple of
years
[Applause]
[Music]
big time finish ain't nothing maverick
run to turn the ball over I'm really
impressed with the week the way Dallas
shears the basketball especially here at
this first one we've been some nice
passes and some excellent finishes just
guys around the room always looking for
open super-happy he's able to finish one
of these dunks excellent pass the
basketball which doesn't surprise me
when we talk about a freaky guy short
every night you gotta gotta like Jordan
in the paint that could really change
things up through the back and beautiful
Venice and powerful tennis by the tower
of power in the Andre Jordan of five
years there but now his first year as
[Music]
once again Moran with the passage short
take the shot like you swimming and it's
simply a pass of top nowhere the end
result will be but on this night the
Suns as DeAndre Jordan on the receiving
end of a lob on a free throw line jumper
Jordan making space were looking they
see me rollin DeAndre Jordan from Luca
uh-huh
he's so good at drawing that'll go on in
my opinion he shoots it too good for it
to be that lonely 39% last year for
three and that nice pass leads to a slam
for DeAndre been pretty quiet since his
big first half and he hits the floor
hard it slides and lost it
Barrett's in transition hair comes
DeAndre a pion down hard
timeout Denver or not to touch it then
he ends up with the jam has lost it
Jordan ahead Clippers get back past the
church when you stack that you take a
bad shot you let the other team off the
hook they go down on the break finishing
strong doc gets it down low to cure he
sitting here in LA for two reasons this
man right here a game on Friday night
here they're worse home loss and 14
years Wesley Matthews by cicuta Jordan
slaps it home with a foul and it's all
Jordan here in the opening minute of the
game
Jordan cutting to the basket seam
drawing the defense letting him fly I
love that harp is still in the top five
and he wasn't even in the three-point
shooting era that is a big time
alley-oop Lucas setting the table port
DeAndre
- foul by the way it said true holiday
to the free-throw line no doubt are
coming right down Broadway for DeAndre
Jordan look at Jordan man did he start
at the free-throw yes I've been a
3-pointer I couldn't tell not quite oh
that's nice that's real nice and the
Harrison Barnes three he made early in
the game he just missed that deflection
Lucas steal what a steal
believes a fast break thought about the
poetry
[Applause]
see Andre Jordan camping out the lane
and the laser pass right to this Dallas
Paul and a tie game we've returned for
the second time out of the game some of
the highlights early on steep or a dunk
for the for time of the game and due for
a hiccup tonight he's at 7 of 7 in the
game with just 70% of the Year who
missed one of these I'm pretty sure on
the floor several times the other night
Luca moves it along to Smith the wild
closeout by Davis and a lot by Smith is
on target and slapped on by DeAndre
Jordan
deniz looking good tonight harp yes long
pass up ahead throwing it down as
DeAndre Jordan and he's fouled good pass
by Cleveland Jordan has been hard to
come by in this quarter for Dallas
[Applause]
bring Senate House down almost look like
it was a pass for DeAndre
that's pretty good defense there in the
open court with Russell
taps it right to Borden to protect that
basketball that's going to have to pave
it a little more force like that that is
some force now as Dallas gets their
first two point field goal bar into the
hard drive JJ in the pace play the first
points of the night for DeAndre Jordan
upstairs and then down hard on the slam
zone
he doesn't always have fun with the refs
I don't get it twisted
Oh Minister with authority to facial by
DeAndre Jordan Matthews with a nice
catch tore the inside with the plus and
a primal scream put a punctuation point
on it
there's dodge chips
just two is five from the field so far
finds DeAndre Jordan on the lob it opens
up the floor in a huge way God good a
lot of easy shots
[Music]
DeAndre down the lane and hammers it
home or speakin of Boothby turnover
frequency teams in the league both up
about 16 game almost
[Applause]
great find the corner for the pass
Jordan had nowhere to go
now the clock is winding down to three
seconds and it's Jordan inside from
Matthews what a mouth Dowson scramble
mode
Jordan the dump from Matthews back to
[Applause]
authority by DeAndre Jordan and he's
fouled to the gym right they up top but
go at these guys ain't no staff Manny
they took Jimmer Fredette instead of
play top hats Berger once with a drive
inside and making sure to clean up the
glass map to you sitting dead red on the
rollers Jordans Bell punched it away and
Matthews Drive lose a daughter short but
there to clean the glass is DeAndre
Jordan timeout Golden State Dallas's
bounce of defense taste
ward stops metal roll
[Applause]
Beverly applauded Matthews warned to the
cash
[Applause]
for DeAndre Jordan efficient offensively
that's a great pass right there on the
road to George Williams around maps he's
got caught up in the street but big
tough defense by Jordan and Luca back in
the game collecting a rebound
[Applause]
the other he turns and sees short
running the floor and up top and down
heart locket three cells will look with
a drive and once again kleva there to
help turn it away makes it fast to catch
but jordan happens is with these
spectacular ghrelin up on jordan jordan
got away
fancy finished no Tippin no
pass it back late clock ciacco Luka got
around it andele lobbed it up deflection
[Applause]
well they give the tenth assist that's a
point five having excellent business I'm
an inch tell their opponents you under
twenty points in the first quarter the
first oxygen late November to be aghast
[Applause]
Elly lasagna for Jordan - nasty stuff by
6:11 tort Smith jr. coming off the
thirty point performance last night yes
Fishlegs at home Raptors have not scored
since that early three by Claude léonard
down the steal by Smith junior the vodka
hustling back Jordan
providing the impetus sky bits play this
myth off the drive goes inside nice feed
inside to Jordan Jordan with the finish
write it in the turnover so they have 15
is this only I was 19 on the seat
nice pass again Dennis Smith history was
really a definite been guarding Smith
daring him to shoot the three shot clock
at five
Smith alley-oop to Jordan throws it down
another perfect lie for Dennis Smith his
sixth assistant linux back up by 12
doing a good job moving the ball moving
themselves under a I'm nipa today with
the stuff
[Music]
alley oop
sniffing Jordan connect once again as we
try to take the Knicks out of the game
join him with the emphatic slam of the
feed from Dotson his first points of the
game that's incredible for 611 guy and
at least the vegan blocked shots but not
that time turn of this none of this jump
watch Turner mr. Salmons jump see
there's been a foul here's booty ain't
driving on Rondo
Lisa voltage it's working around Natalia
swings it to the Pinterest slope a
nuclear-free Jordan
[Applause]
he is not just 13 point 6 of 11 from the
field throws it up and micro WA the idea
of rest man if I could walk I was gonna
play so not only didn't love to play and
he said
[Applause]
and general right and the stylistics
stepwise grandpa that stops it in throws
it to look as you watched it's like I
think he's scared him like he has been
on an unbelievable shooting terrified
but tonight what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content